citizens of the reject Nation it is time we're
gonna do this one more time Greg where are you
going we are going to head to death's Corner today
Roxy it's our final destination two this should be
final destination again two final two destinations
oh see pitched that it's really really good if you
guys want to take the journey with us my pun game
is incredible it is then please do don't forget
to like subscribe all that good stuff I hear that
this one might even be better than the first one
I know literally nothing about it yeah I didn't
know anything about it you told me it was a comedy
so it was it was hilarious yes there was a lot of
physical comedy involved in it thank you so much
to prepper for editing this video and of course if
you want to see more then sync up with us over on
patreon go to patreon.com the real rejects that's
it that's it I was confident she's not a patron
obviously I should be I support the world girls do
you no you don't she has no idea in theory you do
in theory and then you guys get the full length
video watch along with us over on patreon yeah
yeah we did it yeah we nailed it excited two
two final destination two with you poop poop
[Music]
shout out to one of the producers for checking
us out the last time appreciate that oh yeah that
was really kind thank you tomorrow marks
the one year anniversary since valet Air
flight 180 exploded and crashed shortly after
takeoff from JFK Airport that's the last movie
good memories died soon thereafter in a series
of mysterious and bizarre accidents they're an
indication that there are more Sinister
events taking place yeah evil most people
say Supernatural because they think I'm talking
about ghosts and witches and stuff like that well
here's your chance to set the record straight but
she's doing drugs okay well well how do you think
that oh never mind she's trying to get I thought
she had like she's snorting spiders yeah I thought
she had something in her arm for a second and
some people call us okay party Dayton Beach
so I prefer to call it death itself reference
to road trip is this one going to be an actual
Road Trip movie I don't know but Tony Todd's
coming back apparently yes and that's what I
want people to understand the death has this Grand
Design that we all fit into that has nothing to do
with the elements he basically screwed up death's
plan and and that's what I'm trying to warn people
about oh my God it's like reaching the world
yeah this concept this is like the uaps yes yes
so you should be more open-minded you say
Kimberly yeah who is calling her so-called
everyday coincidences what if you could do
something about peace are you listening to
yourself I like this this is some cool World
building here the only way to survive is to
look beneath the visible world it's striking a
different Aura none of them are blinking that's
what I mean there's more of this hypnotic Flair
Roxanne Kimberly you sure you've got everything
credit cards cell phone AAA card yeah it's Daytona
the main character is a woman this time condoms
all right my girl
I'm getting horny I would not let my daughter
be friends with this girl she's a full-blown
adult what are you gonna do I would not allow it
this is why America has standards I've never seen
either of these women before I kind of feel like
they're not gonna make it out it's just because
we're starting with them do you think she's
the lead uh uh no no you're right up period
hi way to hell I forgot how the tone
of Highway to Hell goes I wasn't going
to question Kimmy first you're driving
sorry whoa that's a loud sound [Applause]
was the guy always in the car we're gonna get
like oh dude already I like this group of friends
doing the same thing that they did on the plane
were really hyper focusing on individual sounds
and images the blood the bus good observations
[Laughter]
oh my God are you serious death are you next so
that's wild are you making me a joke right now
no I really don't I have no idea what happens
in this movie isn't that wild did you see that
I know am I dead hey Kimberly it's dead um
hey what's up I'm really proud of that one
yeah yeah uh why is the transmission fluid oh my
God this movie's so much better than the last one
there's a cop minus from the right lane now
not suspicious at all put it out okay Dan put that
thing out wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait just smoke it as fast as possible you're
gonna still smoke it oh wow oh what the hell
no just wait not you what is going on where's
the truck that was in front of them oh oh no
we know these this franchise
isn't afraid to kill babies nope
those things are definitely coming off
the truck 100 that's why I said where
is that truck those logs are about to be lagging
behind
this is one of my biggest fears so what happened
in the movie Under the cave diving the spelunking
movie that we watched The Descent yep that impaled
oh the little boy's warning you who are these
freaks on the road I don't know I drive next to
some freaks too and sometimes I am the freak oh
honey you're dead that
pretty face gonna get ruined
there's a colorful cast of
characters on the freeway today yeah
I can't believe that cop hasn't pulled anybody
over yet stadie you call him that here nah Sadie
it's a Boston thing oh drugs so much you saw
that too I know I feel this movie I'm vibing
I'm freaked by you YouTube none of the drugs
are real it is fake oh no login s be lagging ah
bummer bummer oh my goodness [Applause]
this is so crazy gnarly
practical damage here [Applause]
[Applause]
but maybe like in the last movie maybe she's
just seeing all this and maybe
yeah that's what I'm thinking
that's happened to me with a
water bottle before [Applause]
wow dude
the effects here are amazing unbelievable
[Applause] [__] is just blowing
up We Didn't Start the fight see
I'm gonna try to do what you
did Fall Out Boy no oh [Music]
burn feel death
wow it is like hell is coming for
them why is that truck not stopping
oh easy kidney first you're driving
wow it started way back then and there huh
Bravo I Gotta Give it up man that was a
great sequence that was a great sequence they
really nailed that man I really love how they
blew all that [__] up that was awesome that
was really good we're all gonna die I just saw
it all right that's it my turn to drive no I'm
serious she looks like uh a Gilmore girl and
she's likely to believe it too because she was
listening to the news thing as well yeah yeah
[Music]
God I am so impressed with myself right
now I'm freaked out by you no you should be
I miss I'd like you to please step out of the
vehicle she's got a good 10 minutes before
that happens so she's gotta keep talking I
know usually we could drive around I have a
delivery but you need to get back into
your vehicles now does he believe her
buddy calm down enemy
[Laughter]
Kimberly what's going on
[Music] 180 just like the plane
[Applause]
oh
that was unexpected okay so she stays I
was gonna say we can't not know any of them
oh so I guess these are the
two main characters Maybe
but we gotta find our guy too right he's got to
be back in this our guy from Misawa yeah I feel
like he's dead listen I know you've gone over
all this with Detective subi subie Dooby Doo
like I was there because they don't blame her
like they blamed Sawa she's a woman you feel
softer for her you know couldn't have possibly
done it look I know this sounds crazy but you
guys all heard about flight 180 right yeah my
premonition was just like his ooh premonition
exactly you had a dream about a plane blowing up
so he got all his buddies off the plane and then
the thing blew up just like in his dream
yeah but did you hear what happened after
oh this guy's cool death itself hunting each
one down oh he's a Storyteller oh dead oh
there was one Survivor clear Rivers is in a
padded room at the Stony Brook institution
she lived and we learned that her name is not
Claire it is clear really comments told us that
I'll go now where's the period
blood yeah there should be a trail
how can you possibly determine the trail of
that of who would die next maybe they don't
know it's all random or maybe you would
just think it's whose car was in line
in order or something that's not fun
that's boring you're nothing no your
suggestions no wonder you didn't write Final
Destination oh oh you know I suddenly want
to buy a Mac product this is right when
PC was still doing great things so yeah
dude this guy lives like trash it's like
it doesn't feel like fate as much as it
feels like clean your apartment and
don't die maybe but he drove a sick
car it was posturing I bet he gets a lot
of people yes just spaghetti in his family
this guy's a certified hoarder
yeah but it smells in there oh oh
my God I'm glad he's gonna die like why'd you
keep it if you were gonna just do that hey e
what does that mean I don't
know what it says what's up e
the H fell off hey hey hey or I all right
oh maybe hit something's gonna happen to
his eyes that might be it yeah okay across
nipple ring that's hot and listen I heard
about your lottery win let's hook up call me
yeah oh so he's just blowing all his money let's
get all lottery winners do have you looked into
that huh lottery winners like end up in a it's
horrible it happens to them no no no ah no I
don't wanna no it's not gonna turn on it's not
going to turn on it's cannot turn on we can't
lose his hand first oh go go after yourself do not
do this to me grease it up put some soap in there
I don't want to watch I think it's gonna happen
no way no do not throw that on
there are you dumb oh my God
what was your plan there bro this is
drastically escalated oh he's gonna
cut his own hand off this is like the Saw
movies he's literally gonna cut his own hand
off wow wow he's got to survive he's he's
four he's gonna have to do it oh thank God
that's one of those
break the window
oh the spaghetti he's gonna slip
on the spaghetti that's what I
think he's gonna do oh my God that's amazing
that's out fine but he slips on the spaghetti that
will be hilarious death by
his own spaghetti slippage
slip on the spaghetti [Music] oh okay
Jesus Christ move move oh [Music] that was legit
violent ah horror sequels he always gonna amp
up that door that's very good that was wacky
as hell that was so fun who is Alex Browning
Alex from the last movie which one was that Devin
Sawa oh no no that's Alex don't argue an idiot I
said that to you like so condescendingly too I'm
like come on Roxy you know who Alex was [Music]
he looks right at the camera I want to know what
happened with Sawa maybe he's living in secret I
think that okay falling brick takes life of
falling falling brick uh if you're free of a
falling brick okay clear River see a brick early
that's what took him out a brick no but it said
although the death has yet to and I think it
I feel like maybe we're still not sure if he's
dead or not yeah he's been in the Warwick for
a while though this feels like when like an 80s
slasher movie tone with like the drugs and the
The Whimsy while trying to escape a fire in his
I think so far this movie is having a lot more
fun I still waiting to see if I I kind of like
the characters a bit more in the first one you
know well they're but there were a couple of
friends yeah not friends so I'm waiting to see how
this progresses though he's reading Stephen King
and then tomorrow it's after the dentist to love
because it's important go to the dentist get
your teeth cleaned every six months at least
guys you don't want to deal with a nightmare
clowns oh my God we're gonna kill
the kid who are you calling a kid
the little boy little boy the little
boy who just got tucked into bed like
he is older than that no he's a he's
a teenager he ain't talked in the bed
oh creepy skeleton creepy crawler it's a
Reaper Grim Reaper exactly that's a Reaper
yeah reaping the souls I know I'm sorry I'll
keep all this in the video prepper [Music]
so funny that they decided to
name her clear I feel like it
fits her name with the empathetic nature she had
get directions to New York where did we
establish we were I have no idea Jersey
I mean the obviously shot the [__] in
Canada why you say that it looks like
Canada I'm gonna look it up when this
movie's done I bet you're right yeah
foreign movies that go to psychiatric
places they're always so scary
this is Arkham Asylum you're right so they always
treat it like their lack of sensitivity to people
with mental health struggles but there are some
dangerous people in these spots how many people
died in a freak accident last night what if
the other people are in danger too well if you
put them on the list they're already dead whisper
list death's list duh the survivors of flight 180.
died in the exact order they were originally meant
to die in the plane crash how could you figure out
that order though you said that someone else died
last night that means someone must have intervened
I officer Burke put me away from the crash to kill
my friend once the others are dead it'll come back
for you how is she not dead because Saul I must
have died must have skipped her you said that you
die in the order you're originally meant to but
my friends died last in my premonition not first
wait death is mixing [__] up the guy
in the beer took everything on the road
well don't ignore it recognizing those signs
usually means the difference between life and
death yeah I think Claire is going to die in
this movie but you beat it take a look around
what did I beat Kimberly if you were smart you'd
save yourself and just forget about the others
how can you say that you have a responsibility
[Laughter] how does she responsibility why
and this is what happened to Alex
when I was responsible for him
a brick I feel like you faked it it's a crappy
way to go it's just a brick I don't believe it
everyone gets like a crazy Contraption of a tip I
think it's a death was like [__] I'm just gonna
drop it some brick on it because you're too damn
bitter and selfish to help any other person why
are you so mean she didn't do anything to
you we gotta Speed the movie up that's why
what I like all of a sudden I hate her
Kimberly you're the worst be nice to clear
she's lost everybody well she thinks clear would
have the answers for some reason I don't see how
Tony Todd would have the answer yeah clearly you
should send her to Tony it's funny like the first
one felt like a 2000s movie this feels like an
earlier ERA this feels like more 80s I've been
getting calls all morning from everyone who was
on the on-ramp you believe all this death stuff no
I didn't until last year when I was dispatched to
clean up one of the flight 180 survivors thank you
if clears right about the order then uh Nora
and Tim are going to be attacked by pigeons
I'm not following you they're next on desk
list but isn't it go backwards with you uh
uh yeah that is the newly established rules
poor clear she's gonna leave and you're
right she's gonna die now I think she's
not gonna die though because she's the
only remaining member in the franchise
she's dead this movie I feel like scream
rolls you got to keep somebody alive right
this movie's breaking the rules but
then Devin saw was actually alive yeah
imagine her death by paper cuts like that's gold
that's funny we missed you in here we got hung
up by that accident on Route 23. your mom says
you've been having some pain oh no where are
the pigeons do you have a fish tank growing up
nah nah oh all the water is gonna come out of
the fish the waters back the elements are back yo
it's all about the elements baby the elements man
to be filled oh oh no how many times am I gonna
have to replace those goddamn Windows damn that's
a strong pigeon how many times have you already
replaced them oh no oh no oh no Greg I really
don't like out of everything the regular
Dental [__] because I know I know it's
gonna happen I know what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen what's gonna happen
would you rather just have a laughing gas
you'll be awake a little groggy but
you're gonna be able to move much
you're not gonna be able to move
much oh no oh he's dead he's way dead
of all of the things so far this is the
toughest for me I actually can't watch
oh stop stop
anyway what's happening no no no are
they gonna get there and save them
how are those pigeons strong
enough to pierce the window
[Music]
no oxygen all nitrous they can't go that
gory on a little kid hey what's up with
those fish they're not real fish I
think it's gonna fall in his mouth
he's gonna choke to death stop stop stop
stop stop right I don't know I can't see
no you can't move poor guy that's so
horrible help help that's hilarious
push user oh you can't use his tongue [Music]
that's probably like not again
well I literally just drooled
very stressed out and I
forgot to swallow my saliva
no no [Music] oh you just got I'm
so happy right now this is so funny
okay so she gets skipped because he interfered
that was crazy the deaths are so brutal everyone's
not coming or something no but she's next she's
not next she gets skipped she got saved the rules
are all out the window you know a horror movie's
serious when they kill off a kid a child actor
YouTube you gotta clarify these things because
their AIS are weird I know you didn't ask for
any of this but I don't think you have any
to quit either let's go kick death's ass you
owe her an apology we're like an hour in and
I still feel like I don't really know these
guys trying to remember who's like you know
but man I'll tell you that that stuff
is really fun in this movie this guy
this guy's anyway you seem to know a hell
of a lot more about death than he ever told
wow is this what the outside of his place looked
like in the last one but like what what we never
really established who Tony Todd I mean he works
in a more so he's like so in tune with death
yeah it really amped up like the pulpy
horror zest this time around it's fun man
look at these it's just like a straight up
spook Fest this looks like a Disneyland ride
oh my God emerge from it
so nonchalant we drove a long way to get here
so if you happen to know how to
stop death there are no Escape
you told me death has a distinct design but Alex
and I cheated death not once but dozens of times
I'll watch that is that a rip it
out yeah I don't want to watch that
oh thank God we didn't see it why did
he have to do it like that because he is
so cool because he's cremating him it's
just I don't get why Kimberly is mad at
clear I don't get like clear as mad at Tony
uh you know sometimes you just throw in the
emotion of anger to enhance a scene only New
Life defeat death what the hell does that mean
get pregnant or you gotta sacrifice someone the
introduction of life that was not meant to be
That Couldn't validate the list forced death
Start Anew or get pregnant you might be right
how do you know my
mom he's like the weirdest addition to this
movie that's so great because
it's him but also what oh man
well that is a very Vivid premonition
you were having yeah she has more Vivid
ones than Sawa did I must have lost control
because I crashed into a lake and I drowned
remember the on-ramp there was a pregnant
woman in a white delivery there yeah yeah
she gives birth to a baby that would have died
in that car crash if there's the whole list out
of whack and we start over with a clean slate
seems like a bit of a reach don't you think
whole thing is a reach never came to the station
we had to find her we have to warning about the
lake so she can stay alive long enough to have
the baby and then we don't care what happens
to her vehicle's a delivery van registered to
Marcus and Isabella Hudson the acting in this
feels like it's out of a b movie this time
around too I still cannot believe that you
predicted Highway to Hell I'm still on that dude
man that's what I'm here for hey let go my show
is that dog [__] dude he's the
worst oh you got something on there
where it's still there bro yeah I can get a
fight no oh my God what I don't even see what
he has I think he's just messing what bizarre
scene you're so weird what you're saying is
true that means I'm next first death is
stalking us and now premonitions is what
these were all together why don't you just
pay attention to what happened at flight 8
180 and then realize it's happening right now
trying to make us all crazy [Applause] this
darling that is pure coincidence we need to look
out for each other from now on sleeping shifts
we need to save proof this death trap I think
clear should have been the lead of this movie
yeah me too she's easily the best performer I
think that they're all good but we just like
her best this vehicle's been reported stolen
nice I think everyone's fine I think there's
a lack of chemistry still but everyone is fine as
an individual performer four years ago my husband
died two minutes there's nothing left for me it's
not true honey if we just stick together long
enough for her to have her baby you know if you
excuse me I have a funeral to plan that was one of
my big criticisms of the last one is they didn't
seem to have they didn't seem to care when someone
died so I appreciate it sir maybe it'll scare
these people but I'm not buying that [__] be
careful man even if you don't believe give this to
Nora why would he be able to give it to Nora you
know sometimes you just just like go catch up to
her go with the flow on the any illogical things
wow that is room for disaster
oh move why are you doing that [Music]
why did he do that what if you could just get
so much like anxiety and you attract what you
fear then you could just accidentally caused
some of the stuff to happen to you you know
or you have a heart attack have a heart attack
from the stress yeah it's important to relax
oh he sees it man with hooks oh
he sees it in the elevator it's
funny that like death Rats on
itself gotta give it a chance
people are just uh creepy as hell oh my God
what
I can't hear you what what what is it what a man
with hooks is gonna kill you Saturday is so funny
[Music]
stay still [Music]
cut your hair off
[Music] oh they did establish those are
hard to open [Music] scalper [Music]
is it gonna scalp her [Music] where
they push her in what are you guys doing
[Music]
oh God that's disturbing
bummer
I think he believes now they
found the van Isabel is being
held at the Greenwood Lake sheriff station
this is not the way this is supposed to go
give me the gun Eugene no no no no no no no
no usually don't do it don't do it [Music]
but he's not next you don't keep it loaded
you're all Duds six in a row it wasn't his
turn to die that's so interesting we find the
pregnant woman now please they both look like
Rory from Gilmore Girls it's not your turn to
die I would live it the [__] up like jump off
every building yeah let's put this to the tests
and I get out of here I'm going to really oh no no
no oh that's why they give a car goes in the lake
you gotta deliver the baby my water it just broke
I'm gonna have my baby no you can't do this to me
don't just stand there get me to a hospital just
give me a second to think um second I think just
the most incapable person I've ever met strawberry
I need the car my van my van take my take my van
yes take the van that you believe is stolen
last year my partner and I were heading
out when A call came in about a train wreck
he died that night in a shootout if that call
would come in just 10 seconds later I'd be dead
too we all cheat death let's go start this cheesy
little bed and breakfast in Pennsylvania right
there's this major gas leak that no one knows
about and all the guests suffocated during the
night did the bus I was on splattered some girl
all over the road was that money Abraham the bus
that hit the girl the bus you were on kill Terry
Chaney she was supposed to die on flight 180.
do you guys remember that theater in Paris that
collapsed last year and killed everybody inside oh
my God this this dude I know her just gets whacked
by this falling sign Carter the teacher I replaced
him was Val Luton oh it's all connected who are
these people people got off of flight 180 such a
cool link I did not see that coming that was good
that was really that was good Greg and I also feel
like the actors are forming more chemistry in a
natural way did you drive a little faster [Music]
oh no being alive after we were supposed
to die it caused an outward Ripple if you
had never gotten off the plane we wouldn't
be alive in the first place yes that's why
debt is working backwards it's
tying up all the Loose Ends ah
that kind of checks out yeah it's like
that butterfly effecting oh [Applause]
why aren't you hitting the break are they the
cause for why the baby goes into the water
where are we is everybody all right
[Music]
I gotta go help those people
do you want to deliver this
baby those people can help let's go or
at least call it in yeah officer Adams
reporting a vehicle collision
off 9A at the 180 mile marker
he is the worst he's not a good cop he's
not a good dude [Music] everyone okay
come on you're going to get me out of here
before this thing explodes there's something okay
I think it's okay no oh and look out for potholes
and puddles sir you can't come in
Miss watch out for power I love her
jeez now he's part of it too every person they
save death is coming yeah yeah it makes
you pay attention all these details now
oh no
gas leak that was a really cool shot yeah poop
and if I die um if you throwing all my drugs
and my paraphernalia my porno his waden porno
it's gonna break my mom's heart maybe he
made the porno and my porno that I started
it's the post credit scene final thrustination no
Isabella's at Lakeview Hospital they're
prepping her for delivery we got it we made
it what about cats I'll go talk to her why
did they make it though go on I'll be fine
could you be a little quieter with that thing
please what do you expect I'll just
put it on quiet mode it'll be good
[Music]
yikes
God I would love to play dominoes with death yeah
it's like there's Rube Goldberg [Music] foreign
[Music]
no time to be in shock at all about it I
don't know why can't you breathe [Music]
oh my God is that the baby's POV or Isabella's uh
why are they letting her drive yeah I don't know
I was in a hospital I they were screaming and
a nurse was trying to choke me and I couldn't
I couldn't see her but I could see her Nancy
it was right in my face the nurse was trying
to choke me I think a nurse named collage
why would the nurse try to kill Isabella
the chords around the neck this Baby's in
trouble ironically the woman was impaled
through the head after her emergency airbag
deployed and maybe don't have the news on for
oh and so it begins I don't know about the
Order anymore I think Dad just wants to
clean up man we may need to do a stat cesarean
get doctor Collision up here now Dr Collision
elements
air it really is the elements
that it works with yeah
but why why is she gonna try to kill this woman I
have no clue there's got to be something
it's her husband's baby in there [Music]
oh no no down to 40. God what's up oh I
might have to kill her to save the baby
yeah but you wouldn't strangle her I
mean you gotta do what you gotta do
[Music]
I do like this cacophony of intercutting
between all the different ones
it's a boy
[Laughter]
wait is this the real finale I thought this
is gonna be like a 20 second mislead yeah
I think we're in trouble don't worry
she had the baby it's okay it's over
it can't be that no no definitely
not promo time Kimberly
Isabella was never supposed
to die in that pileup what
she's pregnant herself some bloody hands Gene
I don't understand what's happening it wasn't
the life of her because she wasn't gonna die
anyway it was somebody else's life [Music] no
oh Claire
that's all you're clear would die
you guys have to have sex and make a baby
it took nine months though right yes I
don't know bloody hands you're pregnant
Lake what's happening put
it together faster New Life
I have to die you can't give up now we have
to fight this thing how is you dying New Life
could get collagen I have no idea what's
happening okay I have no clue yeah
[Music]
also who are you trying to save
anymore him just him it's worth it man
if your dad say bye like
[Music]
did she have to drive it into the lake sir
premonition yeah but what
was the get collage in part
um I I guess we have to well it'll unfold [Music]
this at a really beautiful place my God in Canada
apparently Canada is a very beautiful place
didn't you have that drug dealer's
Keys you're supposed to go clear
out his porno I guess he wasn't a
dealer he was a user yeah it's fair
I think it's hard to break glass
underwater in a movie it's easier
I don't know I was wrong only New
Life can defeat death if it is
what's the new life I don't get what her thought
process is here I think she saves
her she doesn't kill her the doctor
right but what's new life this is
her like coming back to life yeah
I think she had to die and then come back yeah
she's back yeah epinephrine two milligrams
figure it out seconds before yeah yeah I
guess but the Strangling and the new life I think
she misinterpreted it thinking that she was being
strangled but it wasn't strangulation we lost you
for a minute okay yeah we did it thanks to you we
cheated death but if she got that premonition
wouldn't death have anticipated this [Music]
all right [Music] Sun Shines on a new
day this is really great Mrs Gibbons
so how are you doing Kimberly had a fun
summer fun Brian I think you better go
check that barbecue well Brian was almost
hit by that news van that day in the field
and your friend Rory he um he pulled
him back at the last second here we go
um hell yeah
sweet sauce
okay so different kind of ending interesting
what what's your initial reaction to that
the ending or the movie the ending I'm glad it
didn't repeat itself where they just die at the
end but is your interpretation that because he
got saved that's why he died and that the two of
them are in the clear or they she cheated death
but he didn't like what do you yeah I think they
broke the cycle but death moved you guys clarified
I think I think they broke the cycle but death has
ah [__] you're right now now it's messing with
my head you know what I mean yeah it is because
they saved him the rules are surprisingly
confusing when they don't when I feel like
they shouldn't be confusing or are we just
confused I don't know if they're as much
confusing as it's like they make up rules
as they go which is totally fine because
it makes for the movie to be so fun but I
am thinking if they say Canadian casting
does that make you think they shot in Canada
why else would they what it's Canadian casting
maybe they're just like nice people it totally
looks like a movie shot in Canada I believed
you I told you I thought you were right
yep good call uh okay so what do you think
go first I thought that was really good like
I I I think I liked it better than the first
one but I because we already knew the premise
going in I think this one had a harder task
and that's why I think I liked it better because
I think it had to do more work to get me on board
and it did take me a little longer I'm bummed
that clear is dead I kind of wish she carried
us through the franchise I still don't feel
confident that saw was dead I feel like he's
popping up again some like late much later
sequel yeah I mean there's five of them right
if I'm not mistake yeah and I think they're
working on a sixth right yeah and we didn't
see his body we just saw that one photo and
I feel I don't know but yeah I wonder if Sava
wanted to come or they wanted him to come back
and then he didn't come back and then so they
just killed him off why do you want me to go
first are you nervous about your thoughts on it
I just want to get my thoughts together okay
what's Your Gut what's your initial like do you
feel like between one and two do you feel like
you have a strong oh I think I think for sure
there's things about this I like more and there's
for sure things I like more about the first one
this one was icky you're like the dentist stuff
that freaked me out the kills in this were so much
uh more intense which I love yeah me too me too
but you and I both were really connected to the
characters in the first one yeah I I wasn't like
massively in love with the characters in the first
one but I definitely cared more and I thought
the especially for our lead character that was
much more interesting I think that the I think
the directing of the first movie had a sharper
direct I think is sharper it was a sharper
craftsmanship I would say in in terms of the
working with the cinematographer and the overall
yes no I now it's confirmed before we weren't 100
confident um yeah the the cinematographer uh
of the cinematography the first one I thought
was a little bit sharper and I thought the
first one had a better grip on tension but
the funny part is I in if I'm not mistaken what I
said in the last movie was I thought in the first
half it started to lose some of I thought in the
last half of the first movie it started to lose
some of its Steam and this one you thought picked
up and I thought this one actually maintained that
fun throughout and that excite that that thing
were because this has started off like city of
Vancouver just wanted to keep taking credit
for that so this this started uh District of
Campbell River that's what I'm talking about baby
yeah um but when I'm so distracted by the credits
this started off fun and I loved the sequence on
the freeway so much yeah that was cool and it just
you like that better than the plane not that it's
all about a comparison but I'm just curious I mean
it's bound to be comparative yeah this is direct
connection it's tying it's not just a soft reboot
or some [__] like it's directly connected to
the first one and it's a sequel so yeah I think
the highway sequence was just so masterfully done
and the the fun of this did main like this feels
so much like a horror sequel in that sense so
yeah we just gotta kind of go bigger and crazier
um and I think that they captured that element
really well I still feel the first one is probably
a better movie overall uh but this is more of the
thing I you know your audience kind of shows up
for because I was I didn't really find this one
like suspenseful or as like fun of an Intrigue but
then again like you were saying it because it's
a part two you're kind of aware of some of those
things like I thought the Intrigue Factor kind of
went down that I would find myself just waiting
for like death stuff to happen and I and I the
characters were nowhere near as Charming as the
first one so like I said there's things about this
one that I think are just so so much better and so
much more fun and exciting and then maintains that
energy but the the first movie I thought just had
a better it was a little more gripping I would
say you know I thought that the reveal in this
one that this was connected how this was connected
to that one yeah was like a turning point in the
movie for me where I was like oh that's super
smart what they did here yeah that's why at the
ending I'm still trying to kind of connect with it
because it's like okay so the premise being that
if you cheat death it doesn't just affect your
life it affects other people's lives who also then
cheat death because they would have been dead too
but you ended up saving their life in some kind
of a way right that's what we were taught I'm
pretty sure yeah and so then that's what we're
taught with that guy at the end um basically
that same kind of thing happened and then he
wasn't able to cheat it so I am still kind of
curious moving forward in this franchise how that
how those rules play but I really when we had
that scene in the car and they're all going
around about how they all have treated death and
and connecting the dots I was like oh yeah this
movie did it like it was that aha moment that I
was waiting for uh that I just thought that they
totally nailed and I did I liked our protagonist
I thought she was good I liked the uh the sentence
I don't always say I liked the cop I thought he
was a good character too I like the two of their
Dynamic I don't know if they were kind of like in
the last one couldn't tell if they were flirting
couldn't tell if we were supposed to be rooting
for them I wonder if there's gonna end one of
these be like a full-blown love story she kind
of kisses him on the cheek at the end when she
was supposed to and I was like I could honestly
as lover love she worships I'd go for make out I
could yeah yeah like you know you're about to
die suck face one last time uh but yeah that
means I thought they had chemistry so I think
that they did a really good job with that too
I yeah what a franchise this is
a good good thriller franchise
yeah I think I think it's good that they
they came out alive at the end because
you they need to have something that where they
can defeat it otherwise what a boring franchise
this would be if if it's just like all right
they're all gonna die because you can't beat this
you know you need to have something where they
can beat it that's a really integral quality to
I think a horror movie like this or a thriller or
whatever I don't know what campus really belongs
to it's me it feels like a horror movie it's about
surviving death on the thing that we rented it on
it's listed as frightening oh really okay it's a
thriller yeah so it's a horror movie I would say
that's accurate was frightening the dentist scene
that had you on the edge of your seat I I had to
turn away something about and I actually don't
even mind the dentist but something about I I
actually can't talk about it anymore I'm sorry it
says look at the Goosebumps yeah this one had a a
cell like I thought the first one kind of lacked
uh a sort of self-awareness like it knew it would
have fun at times but this one's self-awareness
Factor was like through the roof I thought when
it came to the scares and and the sequences too
like they really set out to just have more of a of
a fun adventure time it seems like they were they
they took notes off of things that were like this
is what worked in the last one and let's really
make this work how many years apart were they
um I guess it was 20 2003 let's find out let's
find out um yeah while you're looking for that
where you'll also tell me what I know that guy
from which guy the cop um he looks familiar to you
he doesn't look familiar to me at all definitely I
watch him on some show or something all right let
me look up some stuff here be the best googler
that Google's ever Googled uh you really like
the characters I really didn't I I thought that
like I thought I liked her and him I didn't love
um random girl I don't really like them oh really
I thought they were kind of bland I liked them
I liked them I liked that because of what had
happened he believed her we were on board from the
jump I didn't love the girl it was smart too that
is a smart that's a good point that's a really
smart World building thing I I didn't let the girl
who was the short uh brunette-haired girl with the
log on her lap yeah um she didn't do much for me
the drug dude um I was like I get it I wish that
there was a little more something there um felt
very cartoony yeah the guy that took the gun I was
like At first really on board with him but then he
changed 2000 and 2003 are the release dates okay
you kept feeling like it was like had 80s Vibes I
didn't get that Center at all it had major 2005s
for me um I felt especially because of costumes
I felt more of the this is like the the way they
approached this the switches came out the way
they approached how was it did it go yeah with
the little like like uh yeah it wasn't leaking no
it wasn't you at the dentist uh this this one had
when I said 80s it meant it more in how like an 80
sequel often feels and looks where like the first
one I thought had more and I I could be wrong
about this this one felt like everything was shot
closer I felt like than the first movie of things
were a little bit more widescreen and this was a
little more standard and maybe that's what I was
creepier to me and then um yeah perhaps and then
the um and just the overall I'm talking more like
the aura and vibe that this movie sort of gave off
where like all right we're gonna go like we're
gonna go a little bit more crazy with the kills
here and the characters are gonna feel more like
uh like just archetypes just like like this guy's
a druggie this person's this this person like
everything about it read like an 80s screenplay
but what about the two main characters do they
read that way to you no no no I thought they
were just not that interesting honestly they're a
little vanilla yeah whereas Dev and Sava and even
the the kind of like clears more interesting here
in some ways just because her performance I think
allows her to do more like emoting and more
intensity she was like a completely different
character isn't that yeah at first when she's like
uh I don't know like yeah uh so yeah change your
hair change your life Greg completely different
person um and but in this one I gotta see that guy
you haven't told me I know I'm trying I'm trying
to multitask your Michael you talking I'll look
at him because I know I know him a most popular
characters and and even like the music choices
here like a lot of the music like when the on the
lottery winner a guy was dying they had this like
oh yeah I forgot about the rock music that was
going on here he's Jimmy Olsen and the Lois and
Clark series okay so I definitely know him from
that yeah he's an angel has fallen loves soup okay
so I know from all these uh he's in uh uh I have
no idea what else he's been in oh and the offer
okay yeah there you go super popular guy I knew
him from a lot he's 87 credits on IMDb so it works
and another thing I did like about it too is that
they did they oh yeah that was great a great great
kid death um was the uh subversion of expectations
on like you think you're just getting to the same
setup or they're all in the car okay these are
our new cast of characters who everyone is on this
road trip with them and then they all die except
for that I got that Central and a jump though
that's why I said to you like oh you think that
these two girls are the main characters because
I just got the sunset they the the way that she
was just making such like um uh explicit comments
at the top I was like I don't think they're gonna
keep her that feels like the cast of characters
in that moment they felt like 80s characters to
me like someone you'd see it like Crystal Lake
or something like I'm gonna fry the 13th kind of
movie or nightmare or a Freddy movie in my town
There's a lake called Crystal Lake what's Crystal
Lake on the Friday the 13th movies Jason Voorhees
oh my God I went to Crystal Lake growing up oh
that's a great sign for you you're the one who
had a premonition about Highway to Hell that's
what I'm talking when they're on the highway
and uh they're escaping from Death that's what I
mean by its self-awareness it has more of a like a
tongue-in-cheek flair to it that I really enjoyed
what would you want to see from the third one that
we didn't get in the first two a roller coaster
I saw a roller coaster on the thumbnail foreign
would you want more nuanced characters uh yeah
I mean it's not like a it's not necessarily
I'm craving you know like I want this to be a
character driven study or something like that
I I do think though that it would behoove that or
it would benefit from that in some way of it that
only adds to sort of the excitement and intensity
like sometimes when these deaths are happening
they're just like they don't even really seem
to really react to it after like for example
when that lady got killed in the van uh with the
airbag went off and stuff it was like we used to
go to the hospital now of like someone just died
granted they're not really close with this person
so I kind of get it but that was one of the
things I had issue within the first movie too
was sometime like those are people who knew each
other and then sometimes people would die and it
doesn't really seem like there's much of any sort
of real like oh my God I need a process this no
keep going well we did get more of it this time
like with the guy who went to shoot himself you
know he witnessed her in the elevator and then he
was like like totally lost it the mom with her son
obviously that one made a lot of sense that she
was like if it's my time to go it's my time to go
um that's a consistent thing I think needs to
kind of just carry over when people are dying
yeah I don't love I actually really
dug this I thought it was excellent
I I know I made jokes about it throughout I
didn't love how angry everybody was the whole
time no this has more of a cynical character
approach yeah yeah and I and it's okay to
have some characters that are angry all the time
but like I felt like all of them were pissed at
everybody the whole time and it made it a slightly
less fun for me sometimes because I would like
I you know when the girl when Kimberly goes
to clear yeah I want to be able to relate like
you're in this horrible position and you're going
to somebody for help but the way that she just
comes in guns a blazing and flips her off and I'm
just like I actually can't relate to you at all
anymore like you're being so mean and vice versa
with them um there's just a few characters in this
that I was like oh this is cruel yeah it's just
bizarre how cruel you're being and some people
do get angry in these situations as they these
situations well no the thing is they're they're
playing the one note of anger right and I feel
because the first movie was directed by James
Wong oh yeah uh which I'm remembering and he's
done some pretty great working horror uh before
he Anderson like I think he's even working like
American Horror Story a bunch so uh their names
James W you might as well go into the horror realm
that is the way it goes man um doll you James
so the the holy [__] sorry sorry sorry
damn you rush oh no what was I said the
director of this one versus the director
feel myself going I'm so sorry don't lose
yourself in this one versus the director
and that one with the anger the anger feels
um like like just okay play the note of anger
instead of but there there has to be some kind of
um there's usually something underneath anger
right anger is usually the secondary emotion
of fear sadness yeah and it doesn't ever feel
like it's something from some type of fear or
worry or some type of build up in this movie it
doesn't feel like they're like projecting it or
taking out something but you know those words
really coming from sometimes it was just like
she's got to be angry so make her angry make them
angry because because in order to make a like one
of the things I think happens a lot this is not
the case here but a lot of times when actors
are like forced to improvise in a scene or make
something up a lot of times actors will resort to
we gotta get angry to make it seem like there's a
conflict at hand here like that's the most easiest
go-to emotion and sometimes that felt like it
feels like artificial and kind of annoying here at
times because Tony Todd you guys were saying you
guys are so mad at Tony Todd he didn't do this bro
like you went in for help and you're like we drove
all this way can you please give us the answers
it's like he's a mere mortal he's uh he does also
seem obnoxiously mysterious to the [__] I love
Tony Todd's friends he's so but he's it's like
you obviously know so much more yeah and you are
intentionally just like not giving them [__]
for some reason I don't know why he doesn't give
them anything it doesn't bother me though because
it's him for some reason it's just working for me
I I cannot believe that it is 2023 and I never
saw this franchise with how much this is up my
alley like sure I love big Ensemble casts I love
Thrillers like this I love the way that this is
like super 2000s to me um and I love movies that
keep me guessing Non-Stop and this like even when
you guessed about the fish in the mouth for the
dentist or whatever there's a million things going
on right there's the electricity there's the water
dripping there's the crows are they gonna come in
like I'm constantly guessing because there's so
many red herrings and that's I love that in the
movie so I just can't believe that we haven't
seen this yet have you seen the Saw movies
yeah oh wow oh so this should be nothing for you
I think I've I don't know if I've seen all of them
um but I think I've seen a lot of them
they do the puzzles in the bathroom right
they just do puzzles and bathrooms
I'm right right that's that movie
we got 100 pieces here we just gotta
put them together no no no it's like
you're stuck in the toilet and you have to get
yourself out yeah that's that franchisor yeah
all of them you know I have a hard time
remembering sometimes with the movies gosh
Greg fine I have a hard time remembering with
the Takis sometimes I don't know why movies
don't how a movie makes me feel stays with
me but what happens in the movie dude I'm
the exact same one because I'm such a TV
Junkie too it's just you know ask me what
happened in this movie in a year and I'll be
like I have no idea on the exact same way I'm
the exact same way I just watched Despicable Me
but I am right about the toilet thing yeah yeah
it's all about toilet secret it's a comedy
it's a jigsaw's a plumber what happened to
Despicable Me I haven't seen that oh I thought
like I remember oh you haven't seen it oh damn
um I won't say that uh anyway yeah I think we
is that the Minions movie uh it's the first
one of it yeah pretty much okay yeah I haven't
seen that okay any other thoughts on uh would
we watch yeah I mean we I I don't I don't know
what I think I think which one is the one in
the comments there was even even the producer
uh Craig Perry four is supposed to not be good
that's what everyone says and they're saying and
that makes me want to watch it so bad we gotta get
there you say it's bad I'm like it sounds so fun
there is only one way for us to get there though
and that's what you guys liking commenting
watching the sharing with your friends making
sure that you're going for a joke right the Final
Destination I tell you I was like what you gonna
say because I can't fill in the blinker you know
it's a fact uh you guys if you like this video
we'll keep doing the Final Destination movies
that's how it works yeah that's how it goes it
wasn't a joke it's the only way to operate around
here man solid Truth uh in order to get our to
our final destination I think that's what they
said about the fourth one right the fourth one
is the Final Destination or something like the
Batman but then it's not actually is that what
they start doing I think something along those
lines I don't know this has no subtitle right
it's just Final Destination too I love the the
cover of the third one though the roller coaster
I didn't see it and you did oh yeah I mean you
were gonna see that when we when we watch it so
I was like true or false roller coaster of Love
plays I'm having a premonition roller coaster
and that's why we're not singers okay thanks
guys for joining us on this Final Destination
uh sure yeah yeah keep filling in the silence all
right I'll do it in song I'll do it all night long
keep it going it got weird when I did that uh
my final destination today is going to be to
give the biggest baddest shout outest shout out
to the patron of the day who is none other than
one oh I choose sure Kevin's smart oh I was
hoping you'd say Kevin's smart why because
being from Boston it's the best to say smart
smart yeah he's wicked spot he's Kevin smart
can you give him a Boston shout out he also it's
like mixing Kevin Garnett and Marcus Smart two
previous Celtics players Kevin smart nothing
better than when you're Wicked smack Kevin I'm
just so happy that you're here with us and
that's your Patron and that you're watching
these videos with us and that you love
Greg and maybe you love me we don't know
oh that's good right that was good stoked on it
it was like can you say my name normal dog no man
that sounds great yeah it's a uh the least sexy
accent in America Boston how about this let's
try this out can we do an acronym for Kevin
but make every letter for him something from
Boston okay is for kelly green like the green
monster oh my God this is working e is for
um evil like how people think massholes are V is
for Vineyard Vines oh [__] which is starting
Martha's Vineyard part of Massachusetts I is for
I see you Kevin you Wicked spot um n is for Newton
which is where I'm from in Massachusetts oh dude
you did it oh I thought you're gonna make me do
the whole name that's just Kevin yeah oh good I
kind of nailed that kind of you full-heartedly
bucket just like you Kevin smart oh thanks
dude man appreciate you okay bye foreign